The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So we're going to
start directly today and look
at chain reactions.
And explosions.
So chain reactions, how
many people have
heard of chain reactions?
Lot of people have heard
of chain reactions.
Have seen chain reactions
done, in kinetics.
No.
Alright, well, then I'll
do chain reactions.
Chain reactions.
Chain reactions are reactions
that feed on themselves.
And there are three parts
to a chain reaction.
There's an initiation step,
which is where your reactant
makes an intermediate.
And that's usually
a slow step.
There's a propagation step,
where the intermediate reacts
with your reactant, becomes
a feedstock.
And then there's some
intermediate plus maybe a
first product.
Then there's that second
intermediate, can further
react to re-form the initial
intermediate.
And that's the loop.
That's the loop of the
chain reaction.
Plus maybe a second product.
And then there's a
termination step.
Which is where when your
intermediate, I1, becomes a
stable product.
Or I2 becomes a stable
product.
Basically, where the
intermediates
come out of the loop.
So if you look at this loop
here, you have your reactant
that comes into the loop.
And then go around the loop.
You create I1, and maybe
a product comes out.
Maybe I1 gets terminated, but
most likely it keeps going
around the loop.
Creating I2, which reacts with,
the reactant at some
point gets included
in the circle.
And I1 comes again, and I2,
and I1 comes, and I2.
And every time you form
I1 or I2, you may
form some of the product.
So this is the initial feed.
Then you go in circles.
Eating up R, spitting
out products.
Keep going in circles.
And at some point the
termination's going to win,
and the circle stops, and
the chain has stopped.
And there are two kinds
of chain reactions.
There's a stable chain and an
unstable chain, where you get
your explosion.
Stable chain, or also called
stationary, chain reaction, is
where the amount of these
intermediates, I1 and I2, are
constant in time.
So you don't build up
any intermediate.
So I1 constant in time, which is
why it's called stationary.
Then you have the unstable,
or non-stationary chain.
Where in that case
your intermediate
increases in time.
So in the example I gave here,
you destroy I1 in the first
step, you create it in
the second step.
Comes back, you destroy it, you
create it, you destroy it
you create it.
For every I1 that you
start out with, you
end up with an I1.
There's no change in the
concentration of I1.
But if instead I put a two here,
than my reactant creates
an intermediate I1.
I destroy it.
Create a new I2, the I2
decomposes, creates two I1's.
So after the first cycle,
let's look at the
concentration of P2 here, after
the first cycle here I
have one I1, and make one P2.
But I make two I2's.
So now I have two I1's
coming in here.
So I have twice this reaction.
I make two I2's.
These two I2's form
two products.
And now four I1's,
two times two.
These four I1's go through
the process.
I get four P2's.
So third cycle, I
get four P2's.
And I get two times
four, eight I1's.
These eight I1's go through,
and I get eight here.
For cycle, et cetera.
So I end up with something that
goes like, so this is two
to the zero power.
This is two to the first, two
to the second, two to the
third, et cetera.
Eventually you get two
to the 25 or whatever
after so many cycles.
And if these are gas phase
products, so if there's an
exothermic process where heat
gets created at any of these
steps here, then you end
up with a problem.
The thing goes out of control.
Sometimes that's a good thing.
If that's what you want to do.
And sometimes it's
a bad thing.
Depends on what you
want to do.
OK, so we're going to
show two examples
of these chain reactions.
One is stable chain and the
other one is unstable chain.
And go through the process of
how you solve for them.
So the first example
is taking, so
let's do a stable chain.
Take acetaldehyde, CH3CHO,
that decomposers to form
methane and carbon monoxide.
That's the reaction.
And here are the observations.
There are two observations.
The first one is that methane
and carbon dioxide are not the
only products that are formed.
In fact, there's a trace amount
of ethane and hydrogen,
dihydrogen are also formed.
That's a clue to something
funny is going on here.
That there's a mechanism that's
more complicated than
just this decomposing in
a first order process.
And the other thing is that
the rate, if you do an
experiment and you measure,
somehow you do a half time
experiment, or an initial rate
experiment, or one of the ways
that we talked about early on,
you measure the rate of the
reaction and you find that it's
proportional to something
to the 3/2 power.
That's pretty weird.
It's not a simple mechanism.
It's pretty weird.
And so those two observations
are clues, usually, that
you've got a chain reaction.
The fact that you have a trace
amount of extra things, that's
usually due to a termination
reaction.
It's not a major product, it's
a minor product that's the
termination of the chain.
And then this funny power
here, in the kinetics.
Of the rate of reaction,
that's also
usually a chain reaction.
So now we have to figure out
if there's a mechanism that
supports those observations.
And I'm going to tell you
possible mechanism that
supports those observations.
And you can do experiments to
show that you can fish out
certain intermediates.
It's not proved that that's the
ultimate mechanism, but
it's at least consistent with
these observations.
More hidden chemistry.
OK, so this is the mechanism
that's proposed.
And then we'll figure out
whether this proposed
mechanism fits the data.
So, the proposed mechanism is
that the initiation step
consists of the acetaldehyde,
CH3CHO,
decomposing into a radical.
Chain reactions often have
radical processes also.
Because the radicals love
to make chains.
To the methyl radical, and
then the CHO radical.
So this is the first step.
It's the decomposition
step, it's very slow.
That molecule doesn't really
want to fall apart.
Then there's a propagation
step.
And that's the methyl radical
plus the acetaldehyde, your
reactant, forming with
the system rate k2.
Forming CH3CO radical,
plus methane.
So that is their product right
here, coming out of the first
step of the propagation.
And then this new intermediate
here, so there's this one here
would be I1.
The methyl radical.
And the CH3CO radical
here, this is I2.
And you have to use that
up in the second step.
CH3CO.
That decomposes on its own.
Rate k3, to form the first
intermediate back, the methyl
radical, plus the second
product, CO.
And then this intermediate
then feeds
the first step back.
And you've got your cycle.
And every point you spit
out your two products.
And this could go on forever.
But it doesn't, because at some
point those two methyl
radicals, two of those
methyl radicals can
get along, can collide.
And in a very easy way.
So we've got a few termination
steps.
You can form two times CH3
radical ethane, C2H6.
Rate k4, let's call this k4.
And then there are other side
reactions that can happen.
For instance, this radical
here, which we
haven't used up.
That can also react.
It's just sitting around, slowly
building up as this
thing, very slowly building
up, because the first step
here is very slow.
You don't need very much
of this methyl radical
to start the chain.
Then you start chewing
up the reactant.
But you're still building up a
little bit of this guy here.
This is a side reaction.
It's not a termination reaction,
because that
radical's not involved in the
chain propagation step.
But that radical can react with
some other species, M,
and it could be any of
the other species.
Because it's just a chaperone.
It's just a, to help this
thing to decompose.
CO plus H radical plus
the chaperone back.
And then that hydrogen radical
here can itself react with
your reactant.
CH3 acetaldehyde, CH3CHO,
with a rate k6.
To form hydrogen gas plus your
intermediate, CH3CO.
And this intermediate can feed
the step right here.
OK, so in terms of the
observations, then, we got the
right products.
Methane, and carbon monoxide.
We've got the right amount of
trace stuff, the ethane coming
out from the termination step.
And hydrogen gas coming out
from the side reaction.
And I should probably have
written CO also forming from
the side reaction - well, CO
is a real product, so it's
happening both from the side
reactions as well as from the
main reaction.
So we've got all the species
taken into account.
And now we've got to show that
this mechanism here, in fact,
gives rise to this 3/2 power.
And I know I won't be able
to do it on one board.
I want to keep all up,
so let me use up.
So the first thing, as we've
been doing in kinetics this
whole time is, you've got to
write down all your rates.
Once you've got that down, and
you haven't made a mistake,
then you basically have
the problem solved.
So you write down all
your rate laws.
Eventually, what we're
interested in showing is the
rate of the reaction,
is that power.
So that's write down what the
rate of the reaction is.
The rate of reaction is the rate
of formation of one of
the products.
Let's say the methane.
So we write down that rate.
How was it formed?
It's formed through
the k2 step.
It's formed through this
step right here.
Which is a second order in
CH3 radical times CH3CHO.
acetaldehyde.
We're going to keep that in
the back of our mind.
Because we're going to
need this again.
Because we want to show, at the
end, that in fact this is,
this rate is proportional
to this funny power.
There's the intermediate
sitting here.
So what's the rate for this
intermediate here is CH3, dt.
There are many places that
it's coming from.
It's being created in the first
step, and so the hard
part here is bean-counting.
Making sure that you've found
all the places where the
species is being created. k1
times acetaldehyde, CH3CHO,
and then it's destroyed through
the second step, minus
k2 CH3, better get your
signs right also.
So there's the destruction,
there's the formation.
Times acetaldehyde, CH3CHO.
Then it gets created again,
through the second step of the
propagation, rate k3.
Radical CH3CO.
And then it finally
gets destroyed in
the termination step.
We've got to put that in, even
though it may be a very small
amount compared to these
other amounts there.
So the termination step is k4.
And it's a second order
process, CH3 squared.
We've got another
intermediate.
We want to write down all
our intermediates here.
Because they're all
related, it's the
intermediates sitting here.
So there are going
to be a couple of
differential equations.
So we've got to write
down the equation
for that CH3CO radical.
And again, you look
at your mechanism.
And you find out where
it's coming from.
It's being created
in this step.
Destroyed in this step.
It's also being created
in this step.
But we're going to ignore that
side reaction for now.
Just to make our lives a little
bit easier. k2 CH3.
You've got to put the
termination step in, but the
side reactions are
not so important.
CH3.
Because if you don't put the
termination step in, then your
reaction's just going
to go on forever.
That's just not physical.
Minus k3 CH3CO.
Creation and destruction.
OK, so now what do we do?
Well, we know it's
a chain reaction.
A stable chain reaction.
Because we don't create more
intermediates than
we started out with.
The first step is always
very slow.
Initiation at this
step is slow.
So we're not making very much
of this methyl radical.
We're not making very
much of it.
And we're not making any
more of it here.
So during this whole time that
the chain reaction is
happening, this methyl radical
here is in small quantities.
Small quantities and it's
not going to change
very much at all.
It's pretty much stationary.
Magic word is stationary.
Stationary means it's
not changing.
Not changing, so which
approximation
does that belong to?
That's a steady state
approximation.
We've got a steady state here.
Chain, which is going blah,
blah, blah, blah, stationary.
Steady state.
All sounds the same.
So that's the clue here.
This is going to be a steady
state approximation problem.
So we're going to put
a steady state here.
We're going to put a
steady state here.
We're going to set this
equal to zero.
We're going to put a steady
state right here.
We're going to put a
steady state here.
We're going to set this
equal to zero.
And suddenly the problem
becomes a
tractable algebraic problem.
Now we have, to solve this,
let's do it in one more place.
Let's put it right here.
So now we have two equations,
two algebraic equations.
Two unknowns.
These two intermediates.
The concentration of these two
intermediates are the two unknowns.
Two equations, two unknowns,
we can solve it.
It can be messy.
But not necessarily tricky.
Just turn the crank.
And computers could do this.
So, let me just write
the answer.
Because I don't want to go
through the algebra.
After you turn the crank, what
you want is to get this out.
You've got your two equations,
two unknowns.
You turn the crank.
And you get that form for the
concentration of the methyl
radical two k4.
CH3CHO turns out to be
to the 1/2 power.
When you do that.
There's the funny
power coming up.
That's going to be here.
And then this is what you
want to put into here.
So, and there's the
acetaldehyde,
sitting right here.
There's one acetaldehyde
to the 1/2 power, times
acetaldehyde to the one power,
that's the whole
thing to a 3/2 power.
So in fact, the rate is
proportion to the 3/2,
according to our mechanism.
And all these rate constants
go into it as well.
And what we find is that the
rate of reaction is equal to
k2 times square root
of k1 over two k4.
CH2CHO to the 3/2 power.
Basically, k prime to an
effective rate times that.
It's a typical problem.
Any questions on this
one right here?
Yes.
STUDENT:: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Here?
Right here.
STUDENT:: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You know, according
to my notes I don't have it,
yes, you're absolutely right.
There's a two here.
Thank you very much.
It's arbitrary.
Where the two comes from, I
didn't want to get into this.
Sometimes it's a matter
of convention.
When you have a second order
reaction, A plus B going to C,
you write your rate of the
reaction, as let's write it
here, k times A times B.
Sometimes we have 2A goes to
C. You have a rate k2, and the
rate of the reaction is, you
can write it as dC/dt, which is
minus k2 times A squared.
But if you write dA/dt, because
of the stoichiometry.
dA/dt concentration for, so you
have that C is equal to A0
minus A, twice.
So dC/dt is equal to
minus two dA/dt.
So minus 1/2 dC/dt is
equal to dA/dt.
So dA/dt is equal to minus
1/2 k2 A squared.
And instead of having the 1/2
here, what we do is we
redefine our rate constant.
So that's k2 prime is
equal to twice k2.
You put a two here,
a prime here.
Get rid of this here.
And there's the two sitting
right here.
Purely convention.
Not something to really
worry about.
You've just got to have it right
at the beginning, and
keep that two in, if you're
going to put it in there.
Does that make sense?
It's the stoichiometry, it's
because of this two sitting
right here.
Then you have a choice.
You can either say the rate of
the reaction is the rate of
formation of this thing.
Or you can say the rate of
reaction is the rate of
destruction of A. And then if
you say that this is the rate,
and you don't want to have any
factors in here, then the two
shows up here.
If you want to say this is the
rate, you don't want any
factors in here, then you're
going to have a
different rate constant.
Purely arbitrary choice.
Good question, though.
Any other questions?
OK.
So, there's another thing about
the chain reactions, a
bit of nomenclature that's
interesting to talk about.
It's the chain length.
And that nomenclature is due to
the fact that many of these
chain reactions are used
for polymer reactions.
Where you use radical
polymerization and then you
have, basically, in a polymer
reaction you'll have an
initiator and then you'll
add a monomer
through a radical process.
And another monomer will add
Another monomer will add,
another monomer will add,
another monomer will
add, and then
you're going to terminate.
And then you end up
with a chain.
A polymer chain.
So your product, instead of
being molecular products, the
product is adding a monomer
to the chain
of the growing polymer.
And then it's meaningful to
talk about chain length.
So that's where the nomenclature
comes from.
It's a number of cycles of the
reaction before you get a
termination step.
So we can define the chain
length as the number of
propagation steps per
initiation step.
That gives you the chain.
Each one of these is
a propagation step.
And there's the initiation
step here.
And this could also be
termination step.
In in a stable chain,
or termination step.
There's a termination
step here.
For every initiation step in a
stable chain, you've got a
termination step.
Because you're not building
up intermediates.
So you create it.
At the end of the chain
you terminate it.
You have as many initiation
as termination steps.
So you have a choice here,
in the algebra.
You can use either one.
So another way, instead
of doing numbers here,
you can also rate.
This is also the rate of
propagation divided by the
rate of initiation.
You just take the derivative of
this with respect to time
of the top and bottom.
Same thing.
So we can also define it as rate
of propagation divided by
rate of, let's say,
termination.
Or initiation, whichever is your
favorite one to use to
make it simple.
So, for instance, in our example
here, the rate of
propagation is the rate, also
the rate of product formation.
Since we have a product
formation.
Rate of propagation is
the rate of forming
this methane here.
So in our example here, the rate
of forming the methane is
the rate reaction here.
This is this right here.
So you can plug this
here on top.
I may not write it down because
I don't want to spend
time writing too much down.
So this guy goes
right in there.
And then the rate of termination
is going to be,
the rate of termination is,
well, let's not use
termination because that has
intermediates in it it.
Let's use initiation.
Since we have a choice.
Rate of initiation.
Either one works fine.
Initiation is k1 times the
acetaldehyde. k1 times CH3CHO.
So there's the 3/2 power,
which, where is it?
There's 1/2 plus, so 1/2 plus
one is the 3/2 power here.
So there's CH3CHO to
the 3/2 power.
CH3CHO to the 3/2 power, then
some effective rate k prime.
And you end up with chain length
going to the 1/2 power.
So there's some k double prime,
so effective rate times
CH3CHO to the 1/2 power.
That's the length of chain.
It depends on the concentration
of the reactant.
And the typical chain's on the
order of a couple hundred or
something like this, usually.
You always have a termination
step at at some point.
Maybe a few thousand if you're
doing polymer chemistry and
sometimes millions, if
you're very good at
doing polymer chemistry.
OK, any questions on
the stable chain?
OK, let's do the
explosion now.
And so this is the
typical example.
Of an unstable chain.
It's the formation of water
from hydrogen and oxygen.
2 H2O.
That's the reaction.
Gas phase reaction.
And the observation is that
that, well, you know the
observation.
You put a spark in a balloon
that contains hydrogen and
oxygen and get an explosion.
So we're going to have
to account for that.
Sometimes you don't
get an explosion.
Sometimes it kind
of peters out.
You have a drop of
water coming out.
Not bad.
And there's a temperature
dependence to it also.
So, whatever mechanism we put in
there needs to account for
all the pressure dependence, the
stoichiometry dependence,
and the temperature
dependence.
So this is the mechanism
that's proposed.
Initiation.
You have your hydrogen
molecule.
Spark, or something slow
that decomposes it to
two hydrogen radicals.
This could be a spark plug,
and every time you make a
little bit of the radical.
Then you have a branching
step.
Where your radical reacts with
the oxygen molecule to form a
hydroxyl radical.
Plus an oxygen.
Oxygen atom plus your hydrogen
gas, your reactant, reacts to
form more hydroxyl radical plus
the initial intermediate.
And then the hydroxyl radical,
I don't know why I have
parentheses here, hydroxyl
radical reacts with the
reactant again, the hydrogen
gas, k3, to form more of the
initial intermediate plus
water, your product.
So there are three steps
to the branching here.
You get one intermediate, one
of the initial intermediates
here coming in.
Forms a second intermediate.
OH radical.
Two OH radicals.
And the OH radicals
form the hydrogen.
There's also radical hydrogen
that's formed right here.
So you have this formation.
So because you're forming two
hydroxyl radicals here, in
this step here you're actually
forming the equivalent of two
hydrogen radicals.
So, one hydrogen atom here.
After going through the
branching, you end up with
three hydrogen radicals.
So you go from one to
three in one cycle.
And the second time around,
you go from three to nine.
The next time, you go
from nine to 27.
Pretty soon you've
got a couple of
billion hydrogen radicals.
And that's the problem
right there.
Or the opportunity.
The opportunity to
get something
that goes out of control.
And there are termination
steps.
That we need to take
into account.
The hydrogen radical
can hit the wall.
Before it finds something
to react with.
And gets stuck.
So if the pressure is
low enough, you know
that's going to happen.
You're going to make
a hydrogen radical.
Hardly any gas molecules
around.
It's going to find a wall,
it's going to get stuck.
It's very reactive.
So that's going to terminate
the process.
Hydrogen radical could re-find
an oxygen and another
chaperone, that's a termolecular
process.
That's an unlikely process.
But nevertheless,
it could happen.
With another termination step,
to form the HO2 radical plus
M. And then that HO2 too radical
can react in a side
reaction to form some
products, but not
be part of the chain.
Yes.
STUDENT:: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: How do we get
three hydrogens?
Because there are two hydroxyl
radicals here.
And so in this step here, you
actually have two hydroxyl
radicals to form two, so I could
multiply this by two.
But you usually don't do that.
So this already tells you what
conditions you're going to
get, with something where the
termination is fast, compared
to the propagation.
Because you have low pressure.
If you can't get that hydrogen
radical to react with
something before hitting the
wall, you're going to be OK.
You're not getting
an explosion.
This tells you that a very
high pressure, where the
probability of having a
three-body collision becomes
high enough, then you're
going to terminate
the chain as well.
Those hydrogen radicals are
going to find oxygen molecules
and some other molecule and form
this radical before you
propagate the chain.
At least some reasonably
high pressure.
So that's the clue here.
What's the strategy?
The strategy is to assume that
everything's going to be fine.
That is, stable.
That's going to be
the strategy.
And then we're going
to do a proof by
contradiction, basically.
We can assume that the
chain is stable.
That we can use the steady
state approximation.
We're going to apply the steady
We're going to find where
that breaks down.
And where it breaks down means
that it wasn't right.
That the intermediate
concentration was too high.
And that means that we're going
to get an explosion.
That's the logic.
So strategy is a proof by
contradiction, basically.
Proof by contradiction.
So we're going to assume that
the propagation, or the
intermediates, are in
small quantities.
We're going to assume that we
can use the steady state
approximation, the d[O]/dt
steady state is equal to zero.
That the hydroxyl radical,
d[OH]/dt, steady state is
equal to zero.
And that d[H]/dt steady state
is equal to zero.
These are going to be
our assumptions.
That all the intermediates
are in small quantities.
And they don't change
very much.
And now we're going to write
down, you write down the rates
that correspond to these guys.
And then you solve.
So I'm only going to do
this first one here.
So you write dO/dt, you see
where it gets formed.
It gets formed in the
first step here.
So it's going to be k1 times H
radical times O2, and it gets
destroyed in the second
step here, minus k2
times O times H2.
You set the steady state
approximation, you get a
steady state.
Steady state here, you set
that equal to zero.
You solve for O, radical
O, steady state.
And you find that it's k1 times
H times O2 times k2 H2.
Then you do the same thing
for the other radicals.
You solve for OH steady state.
And you get some expression
which is in the notes.
I'm not going to write
it down, it's
going to get too messy.
But the expression that I will
write down is the final
expression, which we're going
to be taking into account.
So, this expression here,
for the oxygen atom.
It has the radical in there.
So it's not, we'd like something
that's just in terms
of the rates and either
products or reactants.
And this hydroxyl radical, the
concentration turns out, it
will also be a function of
the concentration of
the hydrogen radical.
So what we really want, I don't
want to cover this up,
let me go on this board here.
So when you solve for this, the
hydrogen atom is where you
get something that's free
of intermediates.
And has just rates in it.
There's a termination rate here
going in the denominator.
Another termination rate
in the denominator.
Times O2 times M, where M could
be anything, really.
Minus, and there's the creation
rate of the first
propagation step.
O2 here.
So now we have to see
whether or not our
approximation was valid.
We made an approximation.
We said the steady state
approximation was valid.
If it is valid, then this
concentration, this pressure
here, needs to be small.
Needs to be small
at all times.
If it's not small, then steady
state is not valid, we have a
branching non-stable chain and
we've got an explosion.
So let's look at the different
possibilities here.
What are the possibilities?
Well, the first possibility is
that as we saw intuitively,
when we wrote down this equation
here, the first
possibility is that we're
at low pressure.
Where at low pressure, then, k1
times oxygen is very small.
Because the concentration of
oxygen is small, the pressure
is small. k5 times the pressure
of oxygen times the
pressure of M is small also.
So k5 T O M, O2 times
M is small.
And they're both, then, much
smaller than k4 times the
time. k4 termination.
The hydrogen radical hits
the wall before
finding anything else.
End of chain.
So in the equation here,
these two guys are
small compared to here.
RI, the initiation rate,
is very small.
You control that
by your spark.
Once a second, once a minute.
Could be really, slow.
Steady state is good.
We don't have an
unstable chain.
No explosion here.
Medium pressure.
You've got a medium pressure
where two k1 times oxygen
concentration is
approximately.
You're building up your
concentration.
This is getting bigger here.
This is a constant.
This is getting bigger.
This is also getting bigger, but
you've got this rate here
and this rate here.
At some point, at some point,
this rate here, two k1 times
oxygen concentration, is going
to be on the order of k4 T
plus k5 T times oxygen times M.
At some point it's going to
be like that.
And then you're in
big trouble.
You're in big trouble, because
you've got a denominator here
that's really tiny.
Could be even, if you hit it
right on the nail, you get
zero in the denominator and then
you're in real trouble
from the math perspective.
But from the physical science
perspective, it's
not being in trouble.
Is just that your approximation
is wrong.
The approximation that
you were in a
stationary state was wrong.
And so that means that in this
case here, if you want to have
an explosion, you've got it.
So you adjust everything until
you're in a situation.
And then finally, you keep
increasing the pressure.
And then if you increase it
high enough, then this guy
here, which goes as the square
of the pressures, is going to
overwhelm this.
Which goes linearly
with pressure.
And k5, the termination step,
O2 times M, is going to be
bigger than two k1 times
the pressure of O2.
And then you've got something
small again.
This is where that's hydrogen
radical here is able to
undergo a termolecular process
before finding a reactant.
Then steady state is valid.
OK.
At very high pressures, you get
in trouble again, because
this hydroxyl radical, this HO2
radical, so at very high
pressure. then what happens
is that you have this side
reaction, HO2 radical plus
hydrogen goes to H2O plus
hydroxyl radical.
So there's a probability that
this radical here finds a
hydrogen molecule.
And then feeds into the
propagation through this
hydroxyl radical that's
the result.
And then that keeps the
chain propagating.
So at very high pressure,
you're in trouble again.
And you get an explosion
again.
So you can plot this as a
function of the pressure.
And we're going to put
pressure, actually,
on the y axis here.
Let's put pressure here.
Put temperature here.
And so for a given temperature,
let's call it
temperature T prime, at low
pressure there's no explosion.
Then there's a range
of pressures.
Where there's an explosion.
Medium pressures.
And then a high pressure
termination wins again.
And then if it's really high
you get explosion again.
You do this for, as a function
of temperature.
And what you find that is a
diagram, looks like a phase
diagram, that looks something
like this.
Where at high temperature, you
get an explosion at low
temperatures, and this steady
state is valid.
OK, any questions on this?
Don't try this in
your kitchen.
Go to the desert if you
want to do this.
Or don't do it either.
OK.